order
hello I'm gonna stop you must excuse him
he's always this right fine Ritalin are
you we are the 3d brothers he's
distracting I'm dignified you may have
noticed my work from films like Hugo or
How to Train Your Dragon wait if you're
the 3d brothers what's the third one
oh he's over there you might recognize
him from movies like Clash of the Titans
or Last Airbender
we call him doesn't count hey doesn't
count
show me your pecs oh um my hand is
slightly in front of my face what does
it matter I'm not even supposed to be
here oh now that's not true yes it is
mom thought I'd make things better but
all I did was draw attention to how
broken everything really is he's always
getting involved where he doesn't belong
okay what is that asshole penning oh the
usual three movies tripe three movies
yes jaws three Friday the 13th three
and don't say spike it extreme oh I
don't want to Friday the 13th Part three
you're doing spike its 3d time to rip
into one of the most awesome hands-on
coolest directors yet again why do you
make me do this to you Robert Rodriguez
no for making tons of impressive films
on a very small budget doing a lot of
work himself his focus was to have the
creativity of the production disguise
how unbelievably cheap it usually was
sometimes it worked sometimes it didn't
and sometimes it did both this is the
case with the Spy Kids trilogy plus one
the first film was so enjoyably bizarre
but visually funny that it was easy to
overlook some of the more awkward
moments the sequel is one to started to
wear off combining genuinely smart and
funny moments with but just when you
thought there couldn't be more teammates
by kids 3d game over to its credit this
is one of the movies that brought three
back into the limelight as a profitable
idea the only problem is it's used as a
more exploitive gimmick than God is to
pure flix is it as bad as say thinking
Sylvester Stallone can play a hippie you
had the children's attention - question
is what are you teaching them this is by
kids 3d the movie begins telling us to
put our glasses on yes thank you because
if we saw this throughout the majority
of the film we will be helpless to
figure out how to stop it
today's feature presentation will also
be in three dimension Alan Cumming is
kind enough to interrupt his nut gouging
of your childhood tour by letting you
know that you only put on your 3d
glasses when the characters in the movie
put them on which they wear not
surprisingly 90% of the movie so why
don't they just make the whole goddamn
thing in 3d what did he want give the
people in the theater a little arm
exercise this is entirely pointless
maybe the strategy was to have the
people say oh the characters seem flat
and not at all three-dimensional whoa
now the characters seem flattened not at
all three-dimensional - in 3d
it doesn't even call it a movie he
probably just dropped boxed into someone
and was like yeah I made this in my
garage call it whatever you want it's
debatable whether or not it's actually a
film personally I'm hoping those will
start a new fad and credit
identification I was here because I
gotten a call it opens with a boys by
kid yeah I'm sure he has a name but who
are you kidding we all just call him the
boy spy kid having left his agency and
turned into a gumshoe don't do it you
son of a bitch I know why the water from
your Park is missing hotel it's winter
man I thought the sequel to Blade Runner
will be a little bit more adult than
this actually the fine thing about this
opening is that the weird stilted acting
is surprisingly kind of welcomed their
attempt at acting out an adult situation
is similar to watching the kids from
home movies make their films they shut
down the park tour in the winter the
people who really own this park
all right cut cut guys that was great
how did that feel good once we shoot on
location this thing is gonna be
incredible but to be fair their acting
isn't the most childish that complete
level 5 untold riches toys and Rises
when Stallone is speaking a movie can we
just have an old lady in the blue dress
hit him with an umbrella and chelsea
laster he plays the toymaker a man who's
been banished to cyberspace but
disguised himself to release a VR game
known as game over which is kind of like
marketing a board game called you lost
voiced by kid heads back home to feed
his small soldiers when Oh God Inspector
Gadget finally assimilated his niece the
OSS could really use you it's good to
take care of your family but remember
one thing
everyone's your family
exclusives that makes no sense you live
in a Rescue Rangers treehouse with
budgie the scary helicopter and that
makes no sense what just tell me George
Clooney is the President of the United
States what the hell's going on
mr. president okay I'll accept this as
some form of reality as long as Clooney
still talks to everyone in a patronizing
tone the fact is there is no retirement
once an agent always an agent now it's
time for you to be a big boy and
reinstate ah his whole acting career is
just saying diplomatically why we all
had to clean our rooms
he tells boy spy kid that girls by kid
is missing so he travels to his old
agency to get some answers apparently
his sister is caught in the mind of
Vincent D'Onofrio I mean the game as it
seems to be a trap for all children the
inventor of the game he wants to enslave
the world's youth with mind-control
please I think we've all purchased EA
games before so boy spike it goes in to
see if he can beat the game save his
sister and apparently alert nobody that
this hot selling game is going to take
over the minds of the children of the
world don't worry they'll release a
patch for it later and if you're
wondering what the evil backstory behind
the toymaker is yes so is the movie the
toymaker hates us for impersonating in
cyberspace all these years made you do
that
who knows was years ago we don't keep
good records we're not even really sure
why we hated Saddam Hussein we think it
had something to do with this ugly
mustache oh look he put his glasses on
well that means you better put your
glasses on oh wait this blu-ray doesn't
come with any we'll just enjoy this
throw slapping of your eyes for an hour
and a half
he hasn't been hieronymus Bosch's
toontown where I swear he tries to
excuse the lame effects from here on out
computer-generated
yeah it's kind of like in Roger Rabbit
turning to the camera and saying we
couldn't get a real rabbit
we just wanted emphasize how
disappointing that is and of course the
three-d gimmicks start right away
sorry
distracting doesn't yet know the
responsibilities of his 3d you think you
see I use 3d as a means to transport
people to another world helping the
viewer emerge themselves into the story
yeah
what does he do well you know that trick
when you're a little kitten you want to
annoy someone without touching them Spy
Kids 3d justice annoy you justice away
I'm not touching justice annoy you I
meant why that's inspired me yeah yeah
don't let this bullet touch you instead
of my fists so he has to outsmart some
terrifying enemies who look more like
the mascot of several math games as he's
transported to Mario maker where he
finds some testers of the game how can I
offer service
I'm res high-risk now bouncy wait wait
wait movie bring that joke to me come on
come on come on spit spot young man high
res you really thought you could slit
that terrible joke by us because you
said it really fast got in the corner
for painfully push puns
I'm more of an abstract visual gag I
just didn't want to move so he tells the
testers what's going on but they don't
believe him so they send them to a level
on the moon gee if only there is a way
to stop their gameplay talk to him in
real life and let them know it's all
true but unfortunately they can
thankfully though this game is
apparently half Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire you do get
additional lifeline call up the family
files so he brings in his grandpa played
by Ricardo Montalban Brooks superior
intellect con carne I don't care what's
totally worth it don't look at me
I choose grandpa whoa
so grandpa welcomes himself to fantasy
planet not really sure how they flew him
into headquarters so fast maybe they
just keep him as storage closet and it
appears he has a history with a toy
maker the toy maker is here you know one
I've been hunting him down for 30 years
to me I don't chase him around the moons
of just this moon until I give him up
to be fair I probably would like the
ending of into darkness if it went this
route
oh I can do more than that
the sad thing is it still looks more
realistic than his plastic chest but he
gets distracted by a butterfly no really
I guess he likes enforcing jdd
stereotypes as boys by kid travels to an
arena even lamer than pokemons stating
oh yes Pokemon fans bring me your
comments at hangar dangerous meal
problem it turns out he has to defeat
Arya Stark in Mighty Morphin Pacific Rim
Jers in order to move on to the next
level
now give Rodriguez this these must be
the greatest movies to work on if you're
a child actor what do I do
just lay down what do i do just move
your arm slightly you're gonna make me
look cool right even though you're not
moving a single solitary muscle I'm
gonna make you look like the most badass
fighter in the world
now Stephen Hawking get in your ninja
outfit he beats her just in time to see
Sylvester Stallone play a wide variety
of characters because if there's anyone
I trust who can play a wide variety of
characters its Sylvester so uh what I
want what we want what we want time on
this planet is over it belongs now to
our youth not if we control their minds
a wicked like stocked the world over
again and cured of his diseases wow I
haven't seen someone so dedicated to
playing such a wide range of role since
Adam Sandler did a high squeaky voice
next to another Adam Sandler doing a
high squeaky voice helped even Stallone
comments and how he forgets he's talking
to himself who are you people
yeah I forget the extent of my
programming powers from time to time
every moment I actually believe that you
existed yeah what other ways do you
think Stallone fool Stallone but they
mistake boy spy kid for a magical
character just called the guy who was
supposed to lead them through the final
level to win so they asked him to prove
his worth in yet another meaningless
detours welcome to app zero chance of
liking this we were going to go with
Mario fart but we thought it'd be a
repeat of a stellar camel poop joke in
the second one still a classic
until Captain America Civil War these
would be the most impressive action
effects ever put on screen maybe food
fight comes a close second I'm using way
enough watching this just makes me wish
I was playing this game instead of
watching it as a movie so it's basically
every bad video game film except I don't
have a good game that goes along with it
never have we seen someone sit lay down
it slightly wiggle with the world moving
around him and such badass glory what am
I talking about these are the
characteristics of a real gamer I have
to go talk to my grandfather to who I
mean I must confer with the wizard of
Atari Sega Mendham yeah young people
clearly wouldn't recognize those terms
hey have you heard this new invention
called ice cream now they think I'm
Simon Quan guy who's going to win the
game for them for our purposes
that's very cool luck they can lead us
to level four more quickly cries he's
always trying to sound friendly he still
sounds like he's gonna torpedo someone's
ass oh I don't plan on letting go
anywhere don't you know the ancient
Klingon proverb that says camel poop
we'll talk about this later of course
until you tell me where the hell I just
went one to beam up
you
so he convinces them all to work
together we all work together we all win
with my strength my brains my cool and
my ox they get to level 3 but it looks
like it's do love the fops as two of
them have to fight and one of them has
to lose in order to move on a look of
anguish er does she really have to pee
I've had to go number one ever since
level 2 and trust me you don't want to
see that in 3d well she can't hold it in
any longer and she switches spots in
order to keep him in the game hey it's
been a few minutes time for another
creepy speed from Montalban you are
causing so much pain and only I can stop
him you know
I think this whole movie was just a dare
by Quentin Tarantino to see if Rodriguez
could get Montalban to be passionately
angry at a butterfly at the Tarantino
just Photoshop this image and was like I
dare you to make a story behind this
they make it to level 4 which means boys
by kid meets up with
by college student at the Toymaker lets
her help the team to make the game more
interesting yeah how unrealistic is that
oh not the villain letting her go I mean
male gamers actually following a girl
gamer like they whatever let that happen
we're going to love mountain we are
we're following the guy now this feels
more realistic but they're attacked by
uncolored Happy Meal toys and they floor
it out of there amazing how much it
looks like he's running isn't it clearly
see giing him what's much more practical
than actually having him run did
everybody just film this movie lying on
a yoga mat so they swim into the lava
and make their way into Mount Doom
there they run into Frodo Baggins who
will think was the evil holy shit I was
just kidding
I guess ties to the faculty formed their
own fellowship if we join together in
battles along he reveals that he is in
fact the guy and that he will lead them
to victory only to be killed few seconds
later oops
dude he was evil around long enough for
me to make a 3d wood joke but the girl
who died earlier suddenly returns this
is Dimitri oh my girl my friend I'm his
girlfriend typical Hollywood romance you
barely know each other you mostly fight
and suddenly you declare you love for
each other she set you up juni
well I'm glad you're right or else you
totally would have decapitated that kid
she's a phony she was programmed to do
that but it turns out she still loves
him so she sacrifices her non-existing
self to save him so it's kind of like
when you abandon Yoshi you kind of feel
bad but do you they go back to the real
world but looks like the toy maker has
been freed and is starting to take over
to settle the score for imprisoning me
all I wanted to do is write the wrong
you know I think the way Rodriguez gets
half of these people as he just has them
Skype their lines Clooney can you webcam
yourself against the green screen yeah
sure hello can you FaceTime yourself and
half the costumes from staying alive you
good oh then Terrence can you put on
your Halloween costume from last year
and just wave your arms in front of a
wall any wall it really doesn't matter
si Senor bill paxton can you buddy ring
the ding ster Steve Buscemi can you just
run out in the middle of the street so I
can put you on a giant Flying Pig Angela
enough that's not the weirdest thing
I've been asked to do I didn't see why
this was called the digital file because
all the footage was emailed to him in
that format where was I oh yeah giant
robot monkeys that you can only see if
you put your magic glasses on that
really needs to be much cooler than what
I'm seeing here but Montalban goes
inside the robot head of Tim Allen and
confronts Stallone simply to say he
forgives them for putting him in a
wheelchair years ago this causes
Stallone to turn off all the machines
crashing his robot with the two of them
still inside into the ground
ha
um no to just know a hundred and one
Dalmatians of no yet let's say Ricardo's
here in still loans here there's no way
dead instantly their bones would be
Dyson a Yahtzee Cup you wouldn't even
recognize their remains how do you even
get the wheelchair on top of that thing
let me see the taint better with those
no no but still still no but it's okay
because everyone learns the true meaning
of family and that excuses 100% of
everything for family to family to jail
you online terrors of destruction by God
you're getting the chair spy kids 3d is
slightly imaginative at times but mostly
just dull the jokes aren't that funny
the acting isn't much fun and so much of
the spontaneity of the other films is
gone because it's focusing too much on
showing off its annoying 3d effects I'm
glad I got people looking at the
possibility of using 3d and films again
but good lord what annoying film is sit
through to realize it and the fun thing
is I actually wouldn't mind playing some
of this as a game Rodriguez can be a
great filmmaker but maybe he also has a
secret calling as a game designer to the
whole thing feels like a game anyway
when that of me much more sense well
it's funny that you mentioned that
because that's actually why we're here
Rodriguez became so obsessed with 3d
that he finally let us completely take
over in his new game the 3d brothers
holy smokes that sounds perfect
well what would you like to do today
brothers I don't care I'm three you're
right we should talk about our
identities and what it says about to
psychologically press triangle to
continue my psychological struggle is
obvious I was a mistake and nobody
wanted me oh now don't say that
did you know mother once told me she was
very proud of you really oh yes in fact
the one she confessed to being
disappointed in is distracting what just
disappointed in me come now you know
this it's why you hide behind that
extravagant demeanor Wow I never
actually considered that press the
square button to continue
maybe we can heal after all but the hard
look deep inside ourselves yes maybe you
have more problems than I thought I've
just been running away from them this is
a horrible game attention have a good
movie would you like to run away from
your problems again and perhaps a
playable environment full of obstacles
no I think I'd rather talk about this
very good now as I was saying there are
several levels to the I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to press X if you want to confront my
feelings of inadequacy coming next week
it's the top 11 Disney Princess
conspiracies find out which one of your
paranoia's are true but you can see it
now under vessels ad free early access
just $3 a month to see tons of people's
videos early as well as a bunch of other
extra features check it out and get the
release scoop
you
somebody ring the ding ster
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing a very
popular and very well rated one this is
the breast cancer research foundation
this is a nonprofit organization
committed to achieving prevention and a
cure for breast cancer they provide
critical funding for cancer research
worldwide fueled vance's and tumor
biology genetics prevention treatment
and survivorship this is the highest
rated breast cancer organization in the
United States with an A+ rating from
charity watching four out of four stars
from Charity Navigator that's damn
impressive they've raised more than half
a billion dollars for life-saving
research they seek out the brightest
minds in science and medicine and give
them the necessary resources to pursue
their best ideas as a result researchers
are able to make discoveries and design
new approaches to address all aspects of
breast cancer and do so in record time
go to their site or their YouTube
channel to hear all the incredible
stories of survival and just how
important this foundation is the
thousands of women and men suffering
from breast cancer depend on us no
institution can conquer this disease
alone but together we can